i'm talking about preventing fishing and
impersonation uh we actually renamed it
to back channel
although i do like trust loops it's a
good name too um which is a new
relationship based identity system
um this work was done in partnership
with incan switch and the new design
congress incense which is an industrial
research lab based out of san francisco
so
this week
statistically probably a few of you got
some sort of phishing scam usually it's
accompanied by some link
pretending to be someone very official
and if you click it you'll probably be
presented with some website that looks
also very official
30 billion dollars was lost just in the
last year to phone based scams like this
one
they also fish by email
using email headers where they can
announce themselves as anyone
these are very lucrative attack surfaces
75 percent of organizations experience
some kind of social engineering attack
just in 2020
how do they do it we need to fix this
right but first we need to understand
how
this happens and why it's so prevalent
so with social engineering there's four
steps
first if you're an attacker these on the
right they're not happy to be social
engineer by the way these are the
attackers
very happy to be attacking you
they're mapping user profiles first they
graph the relationship between user
users and businesses in a social network
to try and understand who they should
pretend to be
and then once they figure out who they
should pretend to be they disguise
themselves as that legitimate actor to
fool targets into exchanging data and
information with them
then they extract some personal
identifying information
and
then inflict more serious consequences
like exploits or ransomware this is the
the newest craze now it's everyone's
talking about ransomware all the time
but usually it starts with the social
engineering attacks
so organizations when they try to
protect their systems typically they
protect from the bottom up
so they secure their infrastructure they
have really robust key signing and
verification processes they do phishing
training and detection and they have i.t
teams entirely dedicated to this
but what if we could take a more
preventative approach
what if we could stop attacks before
they even happen
what if we could prevent mapping and
disguising from being effective at all
so this is kind of
the angle we're trying to take on this
um
we've been doing some research on this
and we
narrowed it down i mean we could also
include everything in the world but we
kind of narrowed it down to this idea of
user profiles being something that we
should tackle as a primary
problem
so people have a nickname and a real
name a profile picture
it's put on some public name space so in
an email that might be like an email
server
or like your local private network
probably has some
ldap or whatever
and it's personalized by each user so
each user says this is me
um
and this is my profile name this is my
real picture and everything here's my
description in my bio my company bio and
all that kind of stuff so this user
profile where i create
my own impression of myself is how
attackers can then create their own
impression of themselves which happens
to look a lot like you
text messages are usually really good at
preventing this actually because they'll
usually say
a phone number or something if that
doesn't exist in your contact list if
that number doesn't exist it'll just say
the phone number but apple is kind of
breaking this
so
apple imessage is actually trying to
intelligently detect who the person may
be and they
try to say maybe this might be alan
murray
all they have to do is say it's alan
murray and then all of a sudden you see
that as though it's a contact in your
list but this reintroduces the attack
vectors present in email that are
avoided in standard text messaging apps
and i'm showing you this because i just
want to prove that companies like apple
with all the money and expertise they
have they're not doing a great job at
preventing these attacks in fact i think
it's because they lack a fundamental
understanding in how these attacks
happen or
are really prioritizing the user
experience
and creating really nice design elements
rather than trying to understand how
these attack happened and prevent them
from happening so
we think it's really important to focus
on these questions um
so we've identified it as a there's some
sort of name space
uh there's some sort of self-announced
user profile where someone can
impersonate themselves as someone in
that namespace
and
it's not indebted independently
verifiable so often these systems
user profile systems are dependent on
some third party
um
like a third party server administrator
or
authority that
deems that this user profile is the
correct one or
valid in some way
so how should we rethink
digital identity for safety
so we have some design principles that
we've worked on
the first design principle is
relationships not namespaces
so a namespace is used to avoid name
collisions between multiple people that
share the same name
but instead we want to build a trusted
network of relationships
so
this is notion
um it's an upcoming popular wiki
collaborative wiki kind of app
a notion namespace is defined by the
email addresses you add to that team
similar to google drive
but they can also personalize their
profile and add a photo and all the kind
of bad things that we're talking about
here um but when we watch how people
collaborate it's actually really funny
like despite all this work
uh that people have put into building
these very sophisticated namespace
systems and user profile systems
people actually don't use them that much
um
so you've probably all seen this this is
actually quite old
version of this but
google drive offers a share link feature
so users can give access to the document
in a video call
so this bypasses the name space all
together like how many times have you
been in the call and someone like can
you give me the link to that doc because
uh where is that thing um
this is a really established mental
model um what if we used it as the
primary method to share resources and we
get rid of the namespace all together i
think people could actually do that and
it would be
a pretty fine user experience people
already do this
so that was the first design principle
second design principle
is recognition
so by recognition we don't mean like ai
or anything what i mean is in the human
sense the user experience sense
the process of understanding that a
person you're talking to is actually who
you think they are
um
so user profiles force the recipient of
a message
to determine if the sender is genuine
or an imposter
phone books are actually
pretty good at recognition like i said
before contact lists
and sms does pretty well
you create a personal memorable
representation of them in your own
personal contact list so
uh
i can name someone becky trombone
because i met them through like a brass
band
and someone else can name them becky
101b because that's their neighbor
where user profile she's always going to
be becky smith everywhere she goes
so
recognition is something we really like
about phone contactless and sms
uh resilient
so i think that this one's really
serious i mean i can make it
you know spend a lot of time on this one
but i'll do quickly uh
when we trust a third party to maintain
our identity we entrust them with our
integrity and privacy of that identity
it's
a crime for any post office employee to
open mail but no such law applies to
electronic messages
so
if an identity dis provider disappears
or decides to cancel their provider
relationship or decides to spy on you
you're
basically out of luck um so it's not
very resilient system that we have
currently
um one example of this
was epic games
where the apple stopped providing
identity services to all the users
um
in the best case this is inconvenient
right so you have to migrate all your
users to a new system but the worst case
is the counts are unrecoverable i'm sure
there are some people who never got to
recover their epic aims account before
it was closed
and so the final one is
secure
um
collaborative app that wasn't secure
it might as well everything might as
well just be public right so um a system
that is secure by design means it
doesn't require it should not require
significant effort to verify security
[Music]
users are habituated to warnings
so
if you expose users to a lot of warnings
they they
start to just
not even look at them anymore so this is
signal on the right and samsung sms on
the left and they're kind of warning you
like hey you don't know about this you
want to add them or you want to block
them but like
after a while people start to get tired
of these kinds of things we want to try
and produce something that's secure by
design and doesn't have so many warnings
apple mail
does this by
providing a check mark when you verify
someone's public key certificate but
it's
not turned on by default this is you
know
we kind of want something that's got the
verification of this but uh
is a little easier to use
so people have thought about this a lot
um like i said pgp
so difficult to use most people even if
you've exchanged a pgp or public key
with someone uh you probably aren't
using it currently with them um
it's not turned on by default and the
key servers are similar where you have
to rely on a third party and you have to
you know
hope that they haven't uh messed with
the integrity of any of your public keys
and also um
if it goes down then you can't get
access to anyone else's public key so
um
social proofs
uh
you've heard of key base before this is
a pretty
it was a pretty big deal at the time i
think they got acquired by zoom now
they they have this idea of where you
post your proof to twitter it's just
like a public key um you can post it to
other different social media as well
like github and that kind of thing but
it's still a global name space
so at the end of the day the burden of
proof is still on the recipient so if i
wanted to impersonate mary poppins
i could just create an account that's on
twitter that looks like her account
um and maybe one of the
the characters is different and copy
your profile photo and everything and
key base would be say yep that's
mary poppins uh but you have to still as
the recipient of a message going to
actually check is at the right mary
poppins
um
it's still a user profile that's
self-announced with id numbers and we're
trying to get away from this user
profile or any dependency on user
profiles
distributed ledgers um i'm really don't
have a blockchain for more than like 10
seconds but basically the only thing
that blockchain will give you here is it
removes a dependency on a single third
party i'd be
all it does is do this which is actually
pretty interesting but there's a very
high technical expertise required for
account recovery and it's still a global
namespace it's by definition
a global publicly verifiable thing so
people can map and disguise themselves
as people so it's not really removing
the mapping or the disguising of part of
social engineering so people can still
catfish you or impersonate you
so there's one interesting thing called
magic wormhole i don't know how many of
you are familiar with it if i was there
i'd probably be like how many of you um
but it's a command line tool where you
can send text or files using a short
code
we thought this was a very interesting
potential
starting place for our new identity
system
there's a couple problems with it it's
pretty easy to mess it up or you know
make sure it works well um
so
basically how this works i'm gonna go
really quickly
um but i'll discuss it a little bit more
later
um
you take a code and you give it to
someone out of band so through some
other communication channel and when
you're both online at the same time
this insecure pace server slash transit
relay
transmits and redeems that
code
and it can be an insecure channel we
actually don't trust the relay at all
which is kind of a cool concept because
anyone can run their relay
and you can switch between relays and
that kind of thing so you don't have to
you're not always beholden to one
particular relay that you have to trust
and then so those codes are turned into
or derived into a 32 byte
elliptic curve keys so these are pretty
strong shared secrets but it's the same
secret on each side right so we're not
there's no id for one person id enough
for another but it's a shared strong
secret that we could use as a pre-shared
key to start thinking about our
relationship based identity system so
this is where we kind of started we're
like huh maybe there's something here
so we have introduce back channel
and i'll show you a little demo
what we came up with
so identities in back channel are
created by redeeming a one-time
invitation code
so once this user by passes this code to
another user both of their applications
generate a strong secret
this shared secret represents the
relationships between those two users
and it's used to generate a secure and
encrypted connection
then they assign a name for each other
so instead of naming ourselves
we name each other and then we can start
messaging each other just like you would
in sms
yep
so we experimented with a few different
ways to do codes as you saw before we
were using numbers that's when we landed
on we also
messed around with
uh text purely text codes or just using
the magic wormhole ones which are a mix
of numbers and codes
i mean word codes
we landed on numbers
um because we think that numbers are
more internationally uh viable
especially across language barriers so
they're also easier to spell and say
over the phone
and it feels more like a single use
phone number
um
the users that we tested this with
uh were very
uh positively associated with the
numbers because they thought oh this is
like
a one-time code or or my phone number um
whereas the words were kind of
off-putting right we have to train
people on a few mental models here try
and get them up to speed so
kind of relating it to a phone number
made it really easy for people to get
started and understand what was going on
it's also easier to understand across
languages like i was saying uh
you can imagine saying deaf hazel lazy
you know to someone who speaks really
good you know english might be nice but
then you have to start thinking about
internationalizing that to like 30 or
100 languages and starts becoming
problematic
um
[Music]
it's also unique to each relationship so
these invitation codes
um
there's no permanent address there's no
equivalent to giving my phone number to
someone because my phone number changes
every minute or it's a one-time
use so uh i have to get a different
invitation code for each person so this
is
a positive thing when we're talking
about phishing right because
because there's no permanent address
there's no spam there's no way for
anyone to just contact me on the blue if
they get my number or guess my number
so what happens when the code is wrong
so it's possible to type in a code
incorrectly that's probably the first
thing that happens
um
so we get one guess per connection
attempt so we're using the same security
properties as magic wormhole
um
so an invitation is discarded with the
correct guess and you have to
generate a new code
so now if there is an active attacker on
the network that's just like guessing
codes left and right like for every
single number possible
you would probably see many incorrect
code errors this is also why we
limit the invitations to one minute you
could change that number but
the cool thing about them only being one
minute
long
is that
it forces people to be online at the
same time so say if i
enable i send you the number
um
and i see that it's wrong and i don't
get in but you see that you get in then
there's probably attacker because i'm
like oh i didn't get in and then you got
in and so uh that's kind of weird so
maybe we would just
uh reestablish connection there
um naming so
once you successfully create a contact
you name them so you're not naming
yourself you're naming the other person
and this name has to be private so what
we do is we save it locally on the
machine
it never leaves the machine it's in our
prototype it's a progressive web app
such as stored in index db
um and it should be unique locally so
you have to choose a different name
should be some verification or
validation here to make sure that no
other name exists on the device
but
any anyone could create their own names
that are same but because they're local
on the device we don't really care about
a global namespace it's a local
namespace that way
so this satisfies that recognition
property of using the same as sms we
have a contact list that's local so i
can say like becky trombone and it's
that's my contact list no one else's
so this is a new mental model right this
is
a
cryptographic key that is assigned to
a person's name
so on the left you see like becky could
show up in multiple ways and different
people's back channel contact list but
if she was on user profiles she becky
smith to everybody or
whatever she self-announced
so this is a totally new way of thinking
about it um
and it's a pet name system so formally
is defined as a pet name system between
system symmetric keys and local first
names so this is
zuko's triangle
where you have
a global
something that's global and unique is a
key so that's the symmetric key
something that's global and memorable is
like a nickname like google.com is a
global and memorable thing and then you
have unique and memorable which is a pet
name which is something that's
unique to me and also memorable
and so we combine the pet name with the
key to create a
a
verifiable pending system
so
like i mentioned i mentioned there's
this relay um
so the way that we do this in a privacy
preserving way is you connect to the
relay using a hash of the key so you
take the symmetric key and do a derived
hash of that and then you announce that
hash to the relay
this means that untrusted third parties
can provide a relay service because
the only person who's able to connect to
that key is someone who also has the
original key otherwise they won't be
able to read any of your end-to-end
encrypted messages
so relays do not learn any information
about the contents of the conversation
but they could record ip addresses in
theory
so yeah this page server and transit
relay just it's totally insecure just uh
it's something that's we think is really
important because of the resilience
property so we have a way in the app as
well for you to change your relay server
to give it a url you can easily change
it to a different server
so
talking a little bit more about how it
actually works we separate the codes
into two pieces of the mailbox and the
password so the mailbox is what is sent
to the relay
in the initial code exchange
so um
the password is what needs to be keeps
kept secret so the mailbox is just a way
to be like oh i'm going to try and comb
i'm trying and connect to these two
computers and if their
sp2 password
exchange is correct then they'll be able
to connect to each other
um
this means that the password in the
mailbox should not be derivative of each
other at all um
and
the mailbox is visible to the relay so
um
[Music]
in theory the relay could guess how many
unique mailboxes or how many unique
users are currently connecting at any
time
um
linking multiple devices
so one of the key things
that people often ask when they're
talking about new systems that are
entirely
radical is okay well can i
do normal things that i would do with
other apps like link my phone and my
laptop and yes we figured out a way to
do that with the system
so i'll just show a little demo
so we borrowed a
design paradigm from design patterns
from signal and telegram where you scan
qr code
this is actually doing the exact same
thing
as
uh the contact adding
so if you notice here
i'm sending a message
and i'm seeing that from the same
perspective on both sides
i'm sending a message to john i'm
actually gonna click in there now
and i when i send a message on my phone
uh
hey this is from my mobile
and i go onto laptop it actually looks
like it's from my perspective
um
so one of the key problems when you have
uh
this multi-device support is what
happens when i edit names on my phone
and then i edit name on my laptop
um i want to see all the contacts all
devices at their updated state so in
order to do this well we use auto merge
which is a crdt a conflict-free
replicated data type
to merge changes so it's just a very
simple list data type
and
the list of contacts
um
and each contact includes uh
the contacts and then you have the
devices
so um
the device list is unique on each
phone and laptop and that
is not replicated but the contact list
is replicated
so originally i had the devices in the
contact list um but i separated them and
if we were in like a classroom i'd
probably do some thought experiment but
we're at strange loop so
i'll just give you the answer but the
device list needs to be separated so
that we can remove devices and stop
synchronizing with them later if they
get stolen
so
when i synchronize with my laptop and my
phone
together they give access to each
other's contact list and they do this
through
a symmetric key that they derive
and then they save that symmetric key as
a device in the device list
so if we lose a device
we create a custom method to revoke the
device access by removing that device
from the device list
not only to remove the device from the
device list we send a tombstone message
so say in this example
the phone is lost
when you unlink the device
a tombstone encrypted message is sent to
the phone
and then the phone self-destructs it's
and then sends an acknowledgement back
to the laptop
and then once the laptop gets the
acknowledgement it tells the user okay
we successfully deleted the phone
uh the phone it doesn't have any
information anymore and we're also never
going to replicate with that number
again so we remove them from the device
list at that point
so this is a
little example demo here that's working
so over here this will link unlink all
devices and delete the data including
contacts and messages
so if you notice on the left it just
wipes it out without telling the user
that it did that
so our overall findings um
i have a few more minutes and then i'd
love to hear live q a
um
this can work for more than just chat so
we prototyped it for chat we also
prototyped some designs for document
review so here's an example of using the
same system this is a figma design
prototype where i'm sharing this
document with someone
and they input their code success
uh
i call them jenny
give her access to the reviews
um
and then i can start seeing as people
comment so it's the same underlying
data types i'm just rendering it in a
different way like this is just a
message from bob where bob has commented
on some line
um
and then i can maybe remove bob from
from it so this is interesting because
maybe bob doesn't i don't want bob to
see jenny's edits so the way people
would do this nowadays is they would
create their own uh
[Music]
they create a different document
for every reviewer that they send it to
for example
here's another one where like location
sharing like the google location sharing
feature
uh we have like an invite code and you
send that with a qr code
um so we experimented with a lot of
different ways of rendering these codes
that was actually a lot of the user
experience work we did so we did we
tested this with journalists
and uh
researchers and non-techies and
designers
and it was really interesting this was
this is probably the hardest part was
figuring out what is the best way to
render these codes in a way that is
actionable and makes sense to people on
the first try using the app
so i landed on this design um
the visual indicator of how long you
have left the qr code is for scanning in
person and the numbers should resemble a
phone number i know we're in the us here
but this is like
a phone number from europe
but it would resemble a phone number i
guess if you were targeting users in the
us you might format it differently but
um
we also experimented with drawing
nicknames we felt like this was a fun
thing that users actually really enjoyed
when they were playing with it um it
also helps to
um really confirm that this is really a
person that
you know um that's contacting you and
you can like
uh personalize that contact list a
little bit it's just kind of a fun thing
that we're experimenting with people
liked
um so we tested this with 12 journalists
and researchers once we got to the final
design and very few mentioned that they
didn't need an account they didn't even
notice that they didn't need an account
or and didn't need to create an account
or didn't need to verify their phone
number or anything so i thought that was
that was a really interesting fact and
that is actually a good thing when
people don't notice something
and they just get started right away
that's that's a great
a great thing so
that was very cool
we also know notice that people needed
some new mental models especially
developers as well
um we have to start rethinking
how how identity works
um and this is going to require
new ways of thinking about how
device linking works how uh profiles
work you know there's no i don't have a
profile i create profiles for other
people so there's some learning that is
probably gonna have to happen here
for users and developers um so we have
some known vulnerabilities this is a
prototype so there is an open source
software implementation
um
the relay is a single point of failure
um
so
although the relay is untrusted and you
can switch relays it's still just uh a
dumb echo server right so it's it's an
echo server um but it has to be up like
if the echo server isn't on then you
won't
uh be able to to use this
so there's some
in the in the paper we outlined some
alternatives for that um you could put
in a captcha maybe
um to try and prevent spammers and
ddosers from like trying to bring it
down but there there are some some risks
involved there with having just like a
single server to do this
um key revocation is tricky like we have
this
uh sophisticated unlink process but you
know
there's probably a lot of edge cases and
things to think about there we don't we
didn't spend that much time on it to be
honest like few months so
you know this is just the beginning
right um and then key rotation is not
included in this prototype so um ideally
you would take this symmetric key and
then start rotating it with every
message using something like the signal
protocol
um but we didn't
implement that because we figured you
know that's kind of like replacing one
library with another like we're just
using web crypto uh right now but it is
possible we did experiment with that we
have an open source prototype for that
as well of
combining sp2 with the signal protocol
and that does work um
so but yeah i think production
applications should we have to think
about these these things if they're
going to try and implement this
so what's next um
so this is a big
um
a very big deal for local first apps
that we build at incan switch so we're
really focused on long-term ownership of
data and we want to be able to have that
data ownership forever
but there's a lot of open questions
regarding synchronizing and status of
messages and who has access to what
so i think that this is
i would like to do more uh
more applications that combine
this kind of approach with back channel
and relationship based identities with
local first software
um
in our prototype there's no storage peer
so if you're not online
if you're not both online at the same
time there's no like peer in the cloud
that's going to like have a copy of all
your data so i mean there's a lot of
work to do
there but um
i think this you know for production
application wanted to tackle these
problems they could definitely do that
pretty easily it's just time that we
didn't put into in the prototype
and then people always ask groups right
uh love to work on groups next so
um
one of the key problems is okay so
if i want to create a group with
multiple people do i have to send each
of them a code individually how does
that work so yeah we could do that it
could be like sms where if you get added
to a group chat or group document
uh
you don't actually know the names of
everybody and you have to ask them like
that's how sms works right now
could be referrals and gossip so there's
some prototypes of this where you can
like
nickname someone else and i can like
share my nicknames to other people in
the group um but i think that have to be
done uh with care so people know that
they're sharing their private names
um and then you can also just
reintroduce user profiles with a
preference for local names but um it
kind of defeats the whole point so but
you know i can see people you know if
you're in a production app and you
really wanted to
to have this as an option for people i
could see people doing that as well
um
i think one of the bigger takeaways here
is
uh how this might be able to be applied
for enterprise
so um
[Music]
if i don't know if you're familiar with
the big twitter hack
but uh
i think it was last year twitter got
hacked and all of
all these companies were sitting like
big names like barack obama and trump
were like
oh give me some bitcoin
um
and this was twitter got hacked
and the way that they dealt with this is
every single person
in the company needed to get into a
video conference with their supervisor
and manually change their password in
front of them
so the idea of
in an enterprise
getting on a video call and exchanging a
one-time code with your supervisor is
not that
crazy of an idea if people are already
doing this kind of thing so there might
be something here about organizational
security to think about for for future
applications
this is the team i'm carissa
uh i led this project along with
ben chris who designed and developed the
prototypes
um with kate and peter who are amazing
advisors
so are there any questions
do users ever run their own relay server
uh we just released this last week so um
i don't know but uh they could yes
um there's a part of the app where you
can go change your relay to a different
relay server
um
if you wanted
and all that code is open source you can
find it on this link
did you did you ever look at the sip
session initiation protocol as a
potential part of this
um
someone sent that to me and we thought
it was interesting and i think it could
be like using conjunction um i haven't
uh we're trying to find part of the
research goals here we're trying to find
something with the most simple
offering for very
for like
small teams who want to build
applications um so i think
yeah i mean i would love to look more
into that for
for future work um
yeah we were trying to reduce as many
dependencies on other things as possible
hey um thank you for your talk i was
really curious how you deal with the
revocation of uh
the device linking
do you have it so that like
you can only look at your messages while
you're online so that once you go online
like you get deleted is that how it
works or like how do you how do you
manage
like someone being able to keep the
device offline and potentially see
messages that already exist
versus like that relocation
oh yeah that's a good question um
i would say in that
train of thought it probably works very
it works very similar to
other apps
um so like if you were
so yeah there is that vulnerability um
because i think like
whatsapp would also probably be the same
if you were totally offline
you would never get the
message to unlink
um
so you could see the messages that were
local
were already downloaded
um there's a hard one i think
uh yeah you could force people to to be
online but i think part of the work here
is like
uh
trying to make something that works
forever um in case the relay goes down
or isn't available
uh or you're not online like we want to
still have apps that work while you're
offline see i think that it's still
tricky and maybe it's a per user setting
um so i think there could be something
interesting that regards to like what
people's risk levels and threat models
are because people have different threat
models some people have a really high
risk of their phone getting stolen and
other people might have a high risk of
their laptop getting hacked or something
so there's um
yeah different threat models for
different people i think that
um maybe some people are always online
and they don't mind
uh
forcing themselves to be online all the
time so
that's a good question
i have a question
i've heard that in like ye olden times
like it wasn't the concept of a single
government name or like i guess people
have different names in different
contexts were you like inspired by this
sort of or or what
am i just talking nonsense
oh no no um
yeah it's a funny one because when we
were first starting this project i was
talking to peter
and he was like yeah well
maybe like
joseph of nazareth
you know is like joe nazareth.com like
maybe that's why email is so popular is
because it follows this conventions of
like my name at a location that we've
been using uh
you know culturally or something but i
think that's an interesting
um a point i always i think it's useful
to go back in history and think about
people's like cultural representations
when you're designing your user
interfaces like this
um because different
cultural representations of themselves
or other people is going to play into
how well they understand the system
so i mean i think i i wouldn't say that
we did much of that i think we were
mostly
inspired by uh
just our work on like social engineering
over the past few years and
um specifically with new design congress
and the work that they had done on this
research so
okay i think we're at time uh thank you
very much that was wonderful
thank you so
see you and get much
[Music]